here with a message to Angelina Jolie
our benefactor this week Donald Trump I
[Music]
check how are you know my name is Chris
wonderful first of all Angelina I know
what you're going through divorce is the
best it's a lot a lot a lot a lot of fun
I've been through several and let me
tell you they go by so fast savor every
moment and can I say something hard
enough can I sense I'm talking already
I'm glad that you're finally done what
all of America has been whining for
years and dump that scruffy pretty boy
loser honestly his movies are absolute
garbage although I did have a few laughs
during 12 years a slave well that's not
a as a terrible show much fun some not
fun at all so much fun Jack it was not
funny so much up and let me tell
you the timing is perfect because I'm
about ready to get a new wife and it
could be you I mean what have you got to
lose
what are you by you're married hey have
you seen Milania she have you seen no
she's a complete and total mess I know
okay I am if people are horrified they
love me are you kidding me I wear my
mother's pearls as a grip
[Applause]
imagine imagine a luxurious life is
first lady constantly making love to me
and I'm a human pile of candy corn
melting on the dash of a dump truck and
I do you right I do you're right
Angelina I promise I'd love your
international group of babies like they
were my own my own little ball of
skittles just think of the things I
could get away with if I was surrounded
by your little community college catalog
of multicultural bonbons Angelina let's
make marriage great again
[Applause]
[Music]